Movement has changed my life,
movement has unlocked a wellspring of confidence.
(soft music)
when you develop an appetite for your own power,
mediocrity doesn't taste so good anymore.
(soft music)
Hey everybody, boy, are you guys in for a treat today?
Because Robin Arzon herself,
the inspiring and highly energetic,
self-proclaimed ambassador of Sweat and Swagger
is back for her fourth appearance,
but very first video appearance on the podcast
to drop truth bombs and deliver the goods on time.
For those newer to the show,
Robin is a former lawyer turned global fitness icon.
She was named one of the most influential people
on Fortune Magazines, 40 under 40 list in 2020.
And she's currently the vice president
of fitness programming and head instructor at Peloton,
everybody's favorite home fitness obsession.
In addition, Robin is a two time New York Times bestseller.
Her books include "Shut Up and Run"
and her latest, which is a children's book,
it's called "Strong Mama."
And she recently released a masterclass on mental strength,
which you can find at masterclass.com.
In addition to catching up on her life
since we last sat down six years ago,
we discussed the hows and why's
of developing mental strength.
We talk about the importance
of unapologetically owning your story.
We discuss pre and postnatal fitness.
Talk about how to say no and own your yeses.
We discuss life pivots,
how to begin a fitness journey and many other topics.
I absolutely adore Robin, she never fails to ignite.
And I should mention
that if this conversation leaves you inspired,
as I suspect it will,
there's much more where that came from.
You should check out RRP 99, RRP 137 and RRP 230,
links to which you can find in the show notes
on the episode page at ritual.com.
So please click that big red subscribe button.
Thank you very much and enjoy the singular force of nature,
that is Robin Arzon.
It has been many years, you've been on the show three times.
We were just chatting before the podcast,
but all of those episodes were in New York City
and generally under super cramped conditions
from one tiny hotel room to your tiny apartment back
in the day.
So it's good to actually have you here in the studio
in Los Angeles, welcome.
I can't wait to catch up with you.
It feels good, congrats on this space, it's stunning.
Yeah, thank you, we love it,
and it's just allowed us to grow and do all the things
that we're gonna talk about today.
I was reflecting back on when we first met,
you remember that, right?
Yeah, yeah, it was in Vegas.
In Las Vegas for that Tony Shay Zappos weekend.
I'm not sure exactly what that was,
but it was super fun.
Amanda Slavin put that whole thing together.
I remember.
We connected and we each got up and gave little talks
and we got to spend a bunch of time touring that area
of downtown Las Vegas
and kind of what that Zappos community had created.
And I just remember we were both very early in our journeys,
but I remember like thinking, "This girl's a star,"
like she's gonna be huge and it's been so fun
to watch you blossom over the years
into what can be characterized
as only like legitimate celebrity.
Like you're on the Today show all the time,
you're in People Magazine, like it's crazy.
Things have (laughs).
Do you have perspective on that?
Like it's wild to have watched your arc.
I guess I have perspective, but then also not.
I'm just in my...
Doing your thing.
In my flow, like I'm super in alignment and that feels,
yeah, I try to zoom out.
I find that ambitious folks don't
or always onto the next thing
without really having that moment of awe,
which I is really rewarding.
So I try to press the pause button,
but I'm not very good at that, I'm always on to the next.
Yeah, it's important though.
Let me reflect it back to you because I do remember early on
and you had game,
it's not like nothing was going on back then,
but the difference between then and now
is pretty significant and you deserve it like you owned it.
And I just remember back then,
this sense of you standing in your strength
and having a certain knowingness
about like where you were headed with a vision
and you executed on that vision.
Thanks man.
Which is cool.
It does feel good.
And I remember meeting you
after your keynote at the Vegas thing and being like,
and just being in so in awe of like,
'cause I had already read your book
and I already knew about you in the ultra world.
So it's fun to see my friends win,
and you're definitely, you're sling.
Well you're somebody who's always been really good
about cheering for other successes
and it's easy to fall prey to competitiveness or pettiness.
Like why is that person getting that
and why am I not getting this?
But I've just found that when I'm in gratitude
and I'm cheering for my friends to win,
like the pie just expands.
Definitely.
It's like getting over that idea of a zero sum game,
I think is really important
in terms of just not only feeling good about yourself,
but being in that expansive growth mindset.
Definitely, and it allows us, I mean, for sure.
Yeah, I subscribe to a growth mindset,
but I also just wanna feel feelings
that are good for my immune system.
And when I'm in that like place, if I'm in an envious place,
I either use the envy as a clue or I keep it moving.
Like if it's not helping me
and it's not strengthening my spirit, I just, I can't.
Well, one of the things you have said,
which is interesting
is you have this sort of counter take on jealousy, right?
Like how to use, like if you're feeling jealous,
that's an indication of what you want,
like pay attention to that perhaps don't descend into envy,
but figure out what it is about that other person
that's making you jealous and fix that within yourself.
Yeah, I've used that.
I mean, that was one of the biggest clues
when I was a lawyer.
That was one of the biggest clues
that I should not be no longer be practicing law.
'Cause I was looking at my friends
who had freer schedules
or more creative pursuits or were athletes.
And I thought, I was so envious of that.
And that was a huge clue.
Well maybe let's back it up a little bit.
You've been on the show three times
so long time listeners know your backstory,
but the show's a lot larger now
and I think it would be helpful to just recap
some of that backstory to contextualize
what we're gonna talk about.
Sure.
So go for it, wherever you wanna start.
I dunno, you probably get asked this a lot,
but I think it's important.
Like you were a corporate lawyer,
you had this traumatic event occur
and it kind of set in motion.
You thinking more deeply about who you wanted to be
and what you wanted to do with your life.
Yeah, that's right, and I used,
so I was held up at gunpoint in New York City
when I was in my early 20s, and I used,
having never been an athlete,
never run a single mile before this incident.
And then during law school, I used movement to heal
and I really healed myself through the runs
and I did talk therapy and the stuff that trauma survivors
are quote unquote supposed to do.
But I found that the runs were the most healing for me.
And I started running a ton of marathons,
some ultramarathons and then ultimately left law.
And I am found my way into wellness.
I'm a leader in wellness.
I'm vice president of fitness programming
at Peloton head instructor, an author, a mother,
I mean I'm like a classic multi hyphenate,
so I wear a bunch of hats,
but yeah, that's kind of my game now.
You hit your horse up to the right
or you hit yourself up to the right horse with Peloton,
'cause you were at the very, very beginning of that
and it must be equally gratifying to see how Peloton
has exploded and become this thing.
'Cause I don't know that early on there was indications
that it would be as successful as it has become.
Yeah, I mean, I really did see the vision
and I continue to see the vision,
I mean the plan is global domination
and I think that's peloton's plan
and that's my personal plan.
So walk me through the evolution of Peloton
from the beginning of getting involved
to how it's matured into what it is today.
Well, initially it was a bike company,
it was a spin studio in Chelsea
and there was always a connected hardware
and software component to it.
But I was the second, no,
I was the second or third instructor hired,
and very much in the nay of this company.
And it was very interesting pivoting during the pandemic
because we had already been accustomed to teaching
to a little red dot, when that camera goes on.
So the cameras were part of it from the get go?
From the beginning.
And people forget that at that time,
SoulCycle dominated everything.
And there was this notion of like, "Well who's Peloton?
Like why would you go there?
There is SoulCycle."
Yeah, I mean, the industry was really running,
as a studio business with a real estate model.
Like if you didn't have X amount of footprints
in however many cities you were irrelevant,
and Peloton really changed that paradigm.
Right, so was there an inflection point
where it tipped over where I don't know,
suddenly you get recognized on the street
or something like that?
Like how was it, what was the evolution of that
where you realize like,
"Oh, this is like way bigger than perhaps I thought
it might be when I first got involved."
The leaderboard started growing.
I remember I had a moment,
one of my Thanksgiving classes,
maybe in 2016 or 2017 had like more members on live
than Madison Square Garden.
Wow.
That felt like, oh snap, that's kind of wild.
And it's been growing ever since (laughs)
now we've got like million over 6 million members.
Accelerated the whole thing, of course.
And so what is it like now?
We have a new studio called Peloton studios, New York.
So we have Peloton Studios, New York.
And then we have PSL which is in London.
So two flagships.
So it's not in Chelsea anymore in that same place
that I went to?
No, we have a beautiful new facility, in Hudson Yards.
Oh, wow.
And yeah, we film yoga out of there,
we film strength, we film tread, we film cycling.
We even have it like an audio only kind of setup.
We're all run on a tread and just record the audio
for our app.
So it's a full blown, I mean, we have,
I can't even, I don't even know how many hours
of live tape we have.
I mean, we're essentially in our work.
Right, yeah, there must be thousands and thousands
of hours of thousands archived classes, right?
And so in addition to being head instructor,
what is the role that you play as VP within the company?
Like what does that look like?
Yeah, well, my executive function
is within the content department.
So the chief content officer is my boss,
and I am an advocate, I guess, for the talent,
and as well as an intermediary, whether it's with marketing,
whether it's with our engineering folks, our product team,
if a fitness expertise is required,
I'm usually the voice in that meeting in that room.
And are you helpful
with like finding the other experts out there
to hire for these particular specific roles?
I don't, as it relates to instructors?
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm usually one of the last interviews
for blessing somebody to come onto the team.
What's the question you ask these people?
I'm kinda a hard (laughs).
I know, like yeah.
(indistinct) If the bus starts with you,
if you're the last stop on the train,
like what does that look like?
This young person comes in with ideas of grander,
like I'm gonna be a Peloton instructor
and then you drop the gauntlet on them.
It's not so much a gauntlet as it is listening
to my gut instinct
because there's always a little bit of artifice
in an interview,
'cause you're putting your best foot forward.
But it can't be like I'm auditioning for a role in a movie.
Because after thousands of hours of teaching a class,
that's gonna erode, and you're gonna see
what's the kernel really there.
And there needs to be a point of view.
Of course, there's an expertise,
I mean, that's like, you wouldn't even audition
unless you have a pedigree of athleticism and expertise.
But you need that authentic charisma?
You have to be able
to host a television show unscripted while sprinting.
(laughs) That's a very specific skillset.
Yes.
When I see you doing your thing,
like it does look so natural, it is who you are,
it's an extrapolation of your personality,
but it's so high energy and me being much more
of an introvert I think, there's gotta be days
where she wakes up and she's like,
"I really don't, I'm not up for it today."
And you gotta go and do the thing, right?
You gotta do the thing.
I definitely have days, but I love it.
I am so charged by what I get to do every day, it's insane.
Like I sometimes I'm like,
wait, so they're just giving me a microphone.
Now that the scale is growing to what it is
and it really is like a network.
I'm like, wait, we're still doing this thing,
like you're gonna make me up,
and the red light goes on and we're just off.
And that is really thrilling.
How much prep do you put into what you're gonna say?
The playlist, like all that kind of stuff
that goes into the classes?
The playlists and the class plan are locked.
So I will know exactly what I'm doing,
especially in a class that is more fitness-focused.
If it's a HIIT class, if it's a Tabata class,
I've been very prescriptive with that game plan.
In terms of messaging and talking points,
that's always, like 99% extemporaneous.
I might have like bullets,
like I wanna talk about mental focus,
or I wanna talk about grit or I'll plug,
or I'll mention like,
remember this story about X training moment.
But it won't be that, that's it,
that's as detailed as it gets for me.
So just get a little elevated heart rate
and it just you're in the flow and it comes out.
Flow, flow state, I mean the definition of flow state
is what I'm teaching.
Yeah, have you ever had a moment though
where you just blank?
No, not really.
No.
No, I'm so focused,
I'm so hyper aware of everything that's going on.
It's crazy how personal the relationship
is between the participant and the instructor.
Like I'm sure you've heard these stories a million times.
Like, oh, you're my friend or you're the,
like my deepest relationship is with my Peloton instructor.
Everybody has their favorite, it's this weird,
it is very much like a cultish thing.
It is, it is.
And now that the world is opening up again,
Peloton instructors had lots of interactions
with folks publicly pre-pandemic.
But now that the world is opening up again,
it's almost like people have this pent up emotion globally.
And then when you see someone
who you did have like intimate workout experiences with
in your home when we were all collectively grieving
and going through a lot,
the outpouring of emotion
that happens nearly on a daily basis is pretty intense.
Like many (laughs) many tears.
Yeah, how does that make you feel?
There's a vulnerability that is like,
kind of jarring in a way
to be like in front of that kind of emotion
is pretty intense,
but also I totally get it because I have used the bike
and used my teammate's classes truly to deal
with a lot of heavy stuff.
So I do, so I understand.
Yeah, it's like, you're the face,
but it represents something bigger,
which is, that was a really hard year, two years.
And this person helped me get through it
by leading me through this routine that was so instrumental
and kind of kept me grounded.
And that is very emotional.
So there's an intimacy to it, right?
It's not like, it's different from a movie star,
like, oh wow, I've seen that person on a huge screen
and they're very good looking and charismatic
versus like this person actually helped me.
So I would suspect like it removes the creepy aspect of it.
Maybe it's a little encroaching
and boundary pushing a little bit, but at the same time,
there's something so beautiful about it.
It's largely beautiful.
I mean, sometimes there's a little bit of like,
boundaryless action for sure.
But for the most part it's really stunning to witness.
Yeah, well, you're good with boundaries though,
you're the queen of no.
I'm very good at--
But let's talk about no a little bit.
Like I'm still working my nos.
(laughs) I love no, no is my favorite word.
Yeah, I use my no to protect my yes.
I say no to most things
and I am pretty famous for slashing.
Like somebody tries to put a 90 minute calendar appointment
on my calendar next week and I was like,
that's literally not gonna happen ever,
like I'm maybe giving you 25 minutes,
and I really own my no to protect the yes.
How do you know when it's a yes?
What's the rule?
It's a hell yes, or it's a no, thanks.
If it doesn't feel like a hell yes,
especially since becoming a mother,
if something doesn't feel like it's lighting me up,
then it's a no.
And of course there's the stuff like you pay your taxes,
you do, there's stuff that doesn't feel great to do,
but it's moving the needle.
You're talking about like opportunities that come your way
and the bigger that you get,
the cooler the opportunities are
and the more tempting they are,
and that hell yes it can be there.
It can be a hell yes but also like this is a distraction
from what I'm actually trying to do,
or it's gonna take me away from being a mother
or those other things.
That's when it gets really hard and confusing.
Like, "Hey, do you want a first class ticket to go to Dubai
and do this cool?"
You're like, "Yeah, I'd like to do that,"
but then you're like,
"Yeah, that's really gonna screw my stuff up,
like I probably shouldn't do that."
Agreed.
It's hard, these are problems of abundance.
These are problem problems of privilege of course,
but I've experienced it
and I'm not as great with the no, it's hard,
'cause I wanna do all the cool stuff.
Yeah, but you gotta access.
Then I spread myself thin and then I like burn out
and I have all these other problems.
Oh my God, but that's so not worth it.
I think about the future version,
like I think about the version of myself
at the end of that journey,
as much as I, to the extent that I can contemplate things
that I haven't experienced yet.
And I think about the burnout version of myself
that I have so much grace and compassion
for that version of myself,
largely when I was doing like the 80 hour lawyer weeks,
any element of that is like threatens who I,
like it just shakes me to my core to even go back there.
And I love--
Meaning like when you were doing the 80 hour weeks
and not having agency over your time?
Yeah, there was a powerlessness
as well as just true fatigue, you know?
And I do love hustling.
I feel like the pendulum has swung that now,
like hustle is a dirty word and people are like,
and I'm like, where's your work ethic?
Like give me a freaking break.
So you just have to be in,
I define hustle as grit and work ethic,
meeting your definition of success and purpose.
And I think those two combined create a beautiful momentum,
but I don't believe in redlining obviously,
and that no pain, no gain mentality is harmful,
but we do have to have an element of grit
and work ethic still.
A hundred percent.
So it's finding the balance.
I think that pendulum has swung a little bit too far
where it's like, don't hustle,
make sure that you're resting.
It's like, look sleep's important, recovery,
all these things are important,
but a lot of the people that are over-indexing on that
don't have any of the hustle to begin with,
and could use a little bit of that.
Yeah, the listlessness, the like...
It's sort of rubber stamping
or permitting you to kind of be the lazy person
that you have been historically, it's misused.
It like makes me break out into hives.
Like I actually cannot.
I can't, I can't, I can't.
So what is the, I know you hate this word balance,
but like what is the fulcrum point on that for you?
Like it's changed, I wanna talk about you being a mother,
but obviously being a mother to an infant changes
that equation quite a bit.
I don't believe in balance., I don't believe that,
okay, I think balance is a harmful concept
when we perceive it to be an even Stephen
that like everything gets the same percentage
of your 24 hour day or whatever that a hundred percent
of you is in the world.
There isn't gonna be balance.
I mean, there are some days
where I'm feeling like I'm giving 20% to my marriage
and my husband's giving the 80%.
And then there are some days where it feels more 50/50,
and then there are some days,
you have to show up in alignment with important to you.
And I guess that is a more palatable definition
of balance to me is what is my short list of values
and what's important.
And so that goes back to like the hell yes
or the no thank you.
Is that if a business opportunity is coming my way
or a philanthropic thing that's pulling out my heartstrings.
Like if it's really not moving the needle on the short list
of things that's important to me,
and the top of that is certainly my family and my daughter,
protecting that time.
The stuff that I am devoted to professionally
has gotta light me up and make me feel like a superhero.
Yeah, the balance thing is tough
because I think it ends up shaming people
because everybody's walking around measuring themselves
against some idealized notion
of how everything should fit on on the daily.
I just don't believe anybody,
particularly people who excel in their lives are living up
to that themselves.
So I like to think of it as being completely present
for whatever it is that you're doing,
and giving it your all, and then toggling out of it
and making sure that all of those buckets
over an extended period of time are being filled,
but understanding and being okay with them not being
on an equal level of waterline
on a daily basis or even a weekly basis,
or even a monthly basis sometimes depending upon
how immersive a certain project
or kind of thing that you're pushing forward involves.
I don't think people understand energy to be currency.
Like if we had currency meters
of our energetic exchanges
whether it's the person in your family that you're like,
"Oh, gosh, so and so is really
just like an energy vampire,"
think what is that expenditure costing you?
And what value are you putting on your own vibrancy
and buoyancy and how are you centering experiences
that reward and really, really allow you to increase
that energetic currency, that bank account.
Like there should be an app with a thing on your,
like that measures that
and then there's like graphs it's like,
you devoted this much energy to your in-laws, this, this,
you devoted this much energy to Netflix
and color code them based upon your values.
Like, so red would be bad (laughs).
I wish.
And then you could be like,
"Wow, what am I doing with how I'm expending my energy?"
But we have that, right?
When we listen to our intuition and when we listen to,
like, we have that innately, but we're very distracted
and we sometimes we don't like the answer to that intuition.
Yeah, it's hard, it's hard.
You have to really be calibrated internally
to have that level of self-awareness.
'Cause I think we all just kind of do it
and we don't concentrate enough
on what that actually looks like.
So yeah, that's a cool idea.
Well, let's talk about being a mom.
I mean, this is the big thing
that's happened to you over the last year, congratulations.
Thank you.
I've yet to meet her, Drew dropped you off, right?
He's coming back?
This is our first trip--
Or you're away, wow.
This is our first trip away together.
What are you doing in LA by the way?
I'm gonna Coachella and I had meetings.
So I had some night meetings in LA business stuff
and then Coachella,
mom and dad are gonna
out on these streets.
First trip away
that you're doing.
It's great, I love being a mom.
Athena is a cool human,
like she's just exudes a level of cool
that is really humbling.
I mean, she's just a cool human, I love being her mom.
It's felt very intuitive to be honest.
I wanna say that it's been,
I mean, honestly, it's been kind of easy.
Like I guess, I shouldn't say easy, simple, straightforward.
Like it's like,
that's my kid and that's my husband and that's my family
and it feels good.
And how do you think about like,
have you developed an evolving philosophy of motherhood
and on that subject of balance or anti balance,
how do you think about continuing to pursue your dreams
and your goals while also being the mother
that you want to be and making all of that work?
I am more ambitious now as a mom, I think.
And I was pretty ambitious before Athena.
I mean, it goes back to some of the things
we already talked about.
Like, I am unapologetic with my no
and I have boundaries that like I will not do meetings,
executive meetings or otherwise with my agents
after five o'clock like, I won't, I put my phone,
like I don't have notifications on my phone.
I don't, like the thing I use as best I can,
the tools in my toolkit as tools, not as tethers.
And I've gotten pretty,
even more intentional about that stuff since becoming a mom.
I also refuse to be a martyr,
to an antiquated idea of motherhood.
Explain that.
That I need to be all things to all people,
that I need to wear every hat all at once,
I choose in any given moment what my primary identity is.
And that's not always Athena's mom,
it's not always Drew's wife,
it's not always an executive at Peloton,
it's not always an author, right?
I'm gonna choose what piece of myself I'm utilizing
and presenting to the world.
And yeah, a lot of times,
especially in the last year it's been Athena's mom
and that's amazing, but I'm choosing when that is.
Yeah, how does it work?
Like speaking strictly about fitness,
like walk me through the prenatal phase
and how you thought about your fitness and now postnatal,
like how you've approached it,
whether it's different or has changed based upon
pre mama, pre strong mama Robin.
(laughs) Prenatal, okay, so I trained
and I taught five days a week live
throughout my entire pregnancy.
It only--
Everyone like fell in love with you 'cause you were like,
this is like, "Oh, she's pregnant,"
like there was a emotional bond I think that you created
with the people that care about you.
Well, I announced the pregnancy on the bike
so that, it was like a very major pregnancy announcement.
But that felt very logical to me
'cause I have shared, parts of my life.
Whether it's my romantic journey or my,
of course as an athlete and as a woman, as a Latina,
like there are aspects of myself
that I infuse into my training and my workouts.
And so announcing the pregnancy felt logical,
especially 'cause I knew I was gonna teach,
hoped to teach throughout my pregnancy
and I had a great pregnancy, so that was possible.
And I continued to run, strength train and cycle throughout.
I got my prenatal certification.
So I did prenatal classes as well for Peloton.
And that felt, I was like, "Oh, I got this."
Postpartum however, that piece of the journey was daunting.
It felt like putting myself back together again,
I just wasn't used to slowing down to that extent
and being that vulnerable, and having no control.
I mean just, there were so many days
that the fatigue was crushing.
I was recovering from a C-section so major abdominal surgery
I mean for probably the first six weeks,
I was like, "Oh, my God,
am I ever gonna moved the way I'm used to moving?"
And the pressure of being
this celebrity fitness personality
and what if I can't do that again
or be that person that I want to be or know how to be?
I had real moments of imposter syndrome,
especially when, we are run like a network.
So I took five months of maternity leave,
but when we were planning for me to come back,
they're like, production's like, "What do you wanna teach?"
We have to put something on the live schedule for X day.
I'm like, "I don't even physically know
what I'm gonna be able to do."
That felt really intense.
And I developed a mantra then during that postpartum period
of consistency over intensity,
because I knew I couldn't go hard in the pain,
which is I'm apt to do,
like that is much more my flavor of intensity.
And I thought just do something every day.
And in the beginning it was literally breath work,
like literally feeding my daughter
and doing 360 diaphragmatic breathing.
'Cause I knew that was gonna repair my core.
That was weeks of that, and then it was walks
and little by little amounting to a lot,
but it was frustratingly slow
and now I'm stronger than I ever have been a year later.
And how much of that did you share transparently
in the Peloton classes?
Because I feel like that on some level
is much more relatable to the typical Peloton person
than all the talk about polishing your crowns
and all of that kind of stuff, you know what I mean?
Like, hey, I don't feel like,
most of the time I feel like I can barely do anything
and now Robin can speak my language
or I can find a relatability there
that perhaps even strengthened your connection
with your community.
Definitely, I was super honest,
especially in those first few classes back,
in that six month period,
my first six months back on the bike
and back in strength classes,
I'd already been doing my own training
during my maternity leave, but it's different.
It's different during, in front of the camera that first,
those first few sprints (laughs) feel like,
am I ever gonna get it back, but your body does remember.
And I think being honest about that journey,
especially as a woman and very anti-snap back culture.
I wanna talk about that
because there is all this pressure,
like how quickly can you get back to where you were before?
And your whole thing is about letting go of what was before
and let's focus on moving forward.
Yeah, And I really,
my refrain was what if a plateau is a launching pad?
What if a plateau is a launching pad?
And for a really long time,
I still wasn't fitting into,
like I'm supposed to wear the new Peloton collection
and I'd have to go back and be like,
I actually still need this other size, you know?
And I had to tell my reframe the story around that
and focus on what my body could do
rather than what size the tag said.
Sure, and it's all good now though, feel strong?
I'm stronger than ever.
But it was little by little amounting to a lot.
I mean, it was truly like the smallest steps.
I remember runs on the west-side highway.
I trained for the, I ran the New York City Marathon about,
I think Athena was nine months.
And I didn't, when I tell you that I didn't look at a watch.
I would old school like map the distance for my runs
and not run with a single stitch of like pacing,
because I couldn't even take that information,
I couldn't be like, "Oh, but your pace was this and da da,"
no way, I showed up to the New York City Marathon
actually having zero idea how long it was gonna take me.
Like I was just like--
It's liberating that way.
It was so liberating and it was a nice,
it was a refreshing back to basics.
Like it was like, I'm doing this because I love it,
and because I feel better doing it
rather than any external gaze.
Yeah, I shared a little thing
about this on Instagram the other day.
My version of that is just getting older
and dealing with injuries,
it's a limited version of what you experienced
on an extreme level,
but at some point the GPS watches and all the stuff
are no longer tools, but they're vehicles to shame yourself.
And at that point they're counterproductive
and I've been spending more time,
like letting go of all of that stuff.
And what it does is it does exactly what you said,
which is, it reminds you why you're doing it,
which is that it brings yourself joy.
And that's really the most important thing.
So rather than like looking where am I at?
It's impossible to look at that
and not immediately measure yourself
against the fittest version of yourself.
Which is a really unkind, unfair thing to do to yourself.
It was so, I mean, I noticed myself doing that
and I did do runs on the Peloton tread and it was,
"Thank God I had it,"
because I literally during nap time, I like, I cobble,
I don't even know how I did cross that finish line,
but I cobbled together.
Like I'm talking like 20 minutes in the morning,
20 minutes in the afternoon, and that would be my run,
when I was supposed to run five miles that day.
Like it was not as I would've had done it
in past marathon training cycles,
but the most important catalyst
was not crossing that finish line,
it was how I was talking to myself along the way.
Talk more about that.
It was, okay so I'll do, so pre-run,
putting on a pair of pants
that were bigger than I have ever trained in before.
Go out, lace up, finish that 10 mile run,
finish that 13 mile run, come back kinder to myself
because I completed what I said I was gonna do,
even if it took me however much longer
than previous versions.
And it actually brought me back.
So when I started running,
after I was held hostage and I started,
started running during law school,
it was the first time I was made aware
of my internal conversation of like the actual thoughts,
whether it was like in first person or third person
that were going on in between my ears.
And I was brought back in that training cycle postpartum
as my ability to either use the words to cast,
what kind of spell am I gonna cast with the words
that are going on internally?
And it was either gonna be, I had a choice,
like, are you gonna berate yourself
for the size of these pants?
Or are you gonna tell yourself,
"Oh my God, like you are outside,
your husband's able to watch the baby, she's healthy.
Like you're healed enough from this post C-section
to even lace up, you were craving to even get outdoors."
So there was an element of gratitude and kindness
that I had to incorporate into that training cycle.
And it ended up being the best four months of training
of my life.
Yeah, it's a choice.
But sometimes it's hard to make that choice.
Like is there a mental trick or tactic that you would deploy
to get out of that negative head space and inhabit
that more positive gratitude-oriented perspective?
Yeah, I would often ask myself,
what do you have right now that you used to dream about
or pray for?
And in the like, specifics, it was like just last week,
you couldn't even go three miles.
So you would've been grateful
that you couldn't even run an hour today, you know?
That actually is my like internal,
that asking myself that question is like an internal reset.
Like I remember the beginning of the pandemic,
during quarantine, I was just,
I was pregnant during the pandemic
and the walls felt like they were closing in some points,
for all of us.
And I started that as a journaling practice,
but I would force myself to answer what is it
that you used to dream about or wish for
that you have right now,
but like within these four walls,
like, and then I noticed like,
"Oh, there's that painting that I got, whatever trip,
or there's the couch that I bought with my husband,
little things that I was able
to kind of put that gratitude filter on
that it really helps.
Initially I mean, there were, of course there were some days
that I was like, "God, this feels cheesy."
But the practice of it really helped ground me
and anchor me.
And was that journaling practice part
of what birthed the children's book?
No, so I've been journaling for years and that is my,
whether it's processing training,
or whether it's listing gratitude stuff,
or whether it's just a brain dump,
journaling really helps is like, keeps me like,
definitely it's like a processing thing,
like an emotional processing thing.
The children's book, "Strong Mama."
I was on my babymoon and I had just finished a--
What does that mean your babymoon?
Babymoon, so it's like a little mini vacation
that folks take during pregnancy.
Oh, okay, I never heard that term babymoon.
Yeah, babymoon, so instead of a honeymoon,
it's a babymoon, and so we were on our--
Before the baby comes like--
Before the baby comes
it's like a couple's weekend or whatever.
And so that's exactly what it was.
We went on a long weekend to Connecticut
and like rented a cabin and the place
where we were staying had like a hotel gym.
And I had taken a bootcamp class with my girl,
Jess Sims on the Peloton app.
And I had gotten back to the cabin
and I was like hormonal filled with endorphins,
feeling all kinds of feelings,
and that's when the book poured outta me.
And it was really like a love letter to the baby,
which we called (speaks in Spanish) at the time,
little one in Spanish.
And that's how "Strong Mama" came to be.
And did you know it to be a children's book
while you were kind of channeling this?
I did, yeah.
And you thought you were gonna write a children's book?
Well, this had already been,
so we had had discussions with my agent of like,
"Would you consider this?
Would you write a children's book?"
And I was like, "Yeah, maybe."
And then we went on the babymoon and I was like,
"Whoa, actually, yeah, sure,"
yeah, maybe turned into yes, because here it is (laughs).
But we didn't have an illustrator at the time.
I had no idea what,
I mean, these were just the words,
and that became the framework.
Yeah, and then it became a New York Times best seller.
It's like so crazy.
It's crazy, it is crazy.
New York Times bestseller.
I just admitted the manuscript
for children's book number two.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, what's that one called?
"Strong Baby."
Strong mother, of course, it's called, (laughs) come on.
So "Strong Baby" will come out in 2023.
That's so cool.
Let's talk about the master class that you did.
This is like, so perfectly suited for you.
Like just watching the trailer.
It's you're so relaxed
and you're so in your Dharma doing this,
like it's such a natural fit
and a great kind of like context for you
to share all this wisdom that you share on the daily,
on the bike that kind of just spontaneously comes out of you
and all of these pithy quotes that end up,
all over the internet.
Well, it was cool to, I'm a student of masterclass,
I've taken a bunch of masterclass, they're incredible.
I mean, they all so excellently rendered.
They're super well done, they're very well curated.
The team is incredible to work with.
Yeah, so when masterclass approached me, I was like,
it was no brainer of course.
How does it work?
Like I've watched a bunch of them,
they're all so well done.
And clearly they try to get,
I'm sure they have different directors for these,
but they get the protagonists like very relaxed
and it feels very natural and spontaneous.
Like how much of it is really scripted?
I'm sure you put a ton of work into figuring out
what it is that you wanted to say in the order
in which you wanted to say it.
Well, when we filmed it, all of the pre,
all of the work was already done.
So it's a lot of interviews before you're even on set,
it's interviews, kind of developing the table of contents
and figuring out, like,
if you were to create chapters of your body of work,
what would that look like?
So it was almost like creating a book proposal,
and like creating sections within like a table of contents
of a hefty book proposal.
But because I knew it was gonna be in a Q and A format,
they're really just creating
that framework in the initial conversations of like,
oh, okay, this will be a chapter on your story.
And then this will be a chapter
on how you have developed confidence
and how you've developed mental resilience
in like these different areas.
And then when you're on set,
it's just a conversation with the director.
So they actually make it very fluid.
Well, it's wonderful.
What are some of the core concepts
that are shared in the class?
Well, it is a lot about my story.
So there's a lot that lives in my book "Shut Up and Run"
that is then in this kind of conversation
that a masterclass student gets to witness
and it's everything from my journaling practice.
So basically it's, I reveal my superhero toolkit.
And in that toolkit, of course, is movement, journaling,
visualization, practice, vision boarding,
everything from kind of identifying your superheroes
and with specificity,
as well as owning your no to protect your yes.
Using your words as a wand to cast a magic spell,
the framework with which I applied,
not only my career transition,
but conquering marathons and old marathons.
And it's getting,
it's like if you unzipped my head
and tried to unpack mental resiliency,
that's what I infused into my masterclass.
We'll be back in a sec, but first, if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change," featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast, it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared therein,
all wrapped in a hard cover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only an exclusively available on our website.
Sign copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc, that's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
What is the thing that's challenging you the most right now,
or really putting those tools to the test?
For me personally?
Yeah.
Probably my web-three strategy,
like right now.
Hold on a second, first of all, I'm just like, wait,
you have a web-three strategy.
Like I'm immediately,
like, should I have a web-three strategy?
What is a web-three strategy?
Exactly, that is my question.
No, I mean, I guess right now I'm in a season of recap,
asking myself, like,
"Do I have the same values as pre Athena?"
Like what is on your short list
of important business opportunities?
Like who or what is on your wishlist
of what you wanna work on next?
Like I have realized a number of the things
that were dreams of mine.
And now I'm in a different stage of my career,
a different stage of like a lot of the seeds
that I planted have germinated, you know?
So now it's like,
I'm having those introspective conversations,
I feel like for the last few years
it was just get the work done.
And now I'm in a place where I'm,
more in a more creative place again.
And that actually is harder for me than just like hustling
and getting the work done.
Because you've arrived at this place
that you aspire to and have it,
so what does that mean in terms of what's next?
Exactly, and I don't do as well having achieved the thing,
I'd rather be in the process to achieving the thing.
Sure, yeah, and does there have to be a next thing?
Great question.
That's the one of the things,
yeah, go ahead, sorry, I didn't mean interrupting.
I think, I want to say
that there doesn't have to be a next thing,
but I'd be completely full of shit.
Yeah, you're too ambitious for that.
I mean, one of the things that I found
is I'm further along, I'm older than you, my kids are older.
People ask me like, what's the big vision?
Like what are you working towards?
And sometimes I feel guilty
'cause I don't have a good answer for that,
but the truth is like, I'm good.
Like, I have ambitions and I have projects
that I wanna see realized and things that I'm working on,
but I'm actually really happy doing
what I'm doing right now.
Like, I feel very fulfilled and in a healthy way,
I don't need my life to be any different
than it is right now.
And sometimes, I judge myself for that
because I too, I'm an ambitious competitive person,
but I think there's something healthy about that.
Like, it doesn't, I'm not doing this to get
to somewhere else, I'm doing this much like leaving
the GPS watch at home.
I'm doing this for the joy of doing it,
and ultimately, if this is all that it is,
like, it's pretty fucking great.
You know, and I worked really hard to get here.
I'm very grateful to have this platform
and the opportunity to talk to people like you,
and it's okay if it's never anything bigger
or more grand than what it is right now,
because it's pretty fucking awesome as it is.
I can relate to that as it...
I feel that way about Peloton.
When I'm on that bike, I'm like,
"I don't need this to be different."
Like, I love this piece of how I serve the world.
But then I also think, what are other ways
that I can be expanding into who I am?
And whether that's licensing and product iterations,
whether that's different platforms that I'm gonna partner
with, different brands, different investments.
Now, Web 3 is an example of like,
just my brain melting into different ideas.
So it's both exciting and also terrifying.
Yeah, because the thing is, those opportunities are there,
and you could immerse yourself or run down a bunch
of different alleyways towards those things.
But ultimately, they end up draining your energy, right?
So it has to be worth it, because otherwise,
it is taking time away from those other values
that you cherish.
And what do you want your life to look like
on a daily basis?
Like, how manageable
or how much agency do you wanna have over your time?
And if you get involved with too many things,
they might all be individually very cool,
and reward you financially, et cetera,
but ultimately, if you're just spread so thin
in the pursuit of those things,
you're losing sight of the most important thing,
which is the quality time with the people that you care
about and making sure that you have the energy
for the things that are most important to you.
Yeah, and I think, sometimes it is like analysis
by paralysis, or paralysis by analysis.
Sometimes that it's, I'm like, "What is the risk?
What's the reward?"
But if it's a totally new venture
and I have no, the newness is what's exciting,
but then the newness is also where I get
completely paralyzed, because I don't actually know
whether that venture is worth it
both financially, energetically, or otherwise.
So the Web 3 thing, I mean,
what does that mean?
Like, NFTs of Robin?
Like, I don't even understand.
Well, I'm still developing the strategy around it,
but I'm a digital creator,
and it's, how will I create digitally in Web 3?
You know, I wanna stay away from anything
that feels gimmicky, where it's just like a piece
of art that I want, that I sell on open sea, just to say,
"I did that."
I really wanna create community
and think about what is an inspired engagement
with Web 3.
I also feel really strongly about having a female presence
in Web 3, it's very male dominated,
especially, it's pretty much white male dominated.
And I wanna, as I'm educating myself, I'm thinking,
how can I build bridges?
So folks that follow me,
especially women and people of color,
can also feel like they're being educated.
So it goes back to that toolkit.
I'm developing my own toolkit.
I'm educating myself around basic terminology
like, what is crypto?
What is a non fungible token?
You know?
And along that process, I'm really trying
to consider who are the right partners in this space,
and how am I gonna build community in this new land grab?
Yeah, that's fascinating.
I feel like now I should be thinking more about this.
Like, what are your sources of information on this?
Like, who are you going to to learn about this?
Well, Drew is very pretty well versed.
He has been involved in crypto and Bitcoin for a few years,
and so it's actually really neat because
for the first time, we're working together
in ways that it now feel faded,
but like, didn't feel timely before, and now it's the time.
Yeah, let's talk about life pivots,
we're both recovering corporate lawyers.
I think you have a greater fondness
for your legal career than perhaps I did.
But people look at you as this inspiration
for changing your life
and constantly iterating on your path.
And I'm sure people come to you all the time and say,
"I'm unhappy in my chosen career,"
or, "I'm looking for a change."
Like, how did you do it?
I really, I did a three part.
I only now understand this as a three-part audit,
but I did a three-part audit when I was a lawyer.
So I realized that I had fallen in love
with running and movement,
and it was a two-year journey
from that ideation phase to the departure phase.
And in those two years, I did a three-part audit.
I would say one was a physical audit of like,
how am I feel feeling in my physical body?
Like, energy is currency, like,
how can I capitalize on the energy that I'm feeling,
and what are the avenues and the tools
that I am feeling more filled with energy?
Then the second was a more existential question of like,
and I had a lot of this,
especially in my 20s after the hostage situation of like,
"What am I doing?
Why am I here?
Why did I survive?
Who am I?"
And then the third was a very bras tax,
like financial audit of how the hell
am I gonna pay my rent in New York City?
How can I not move in with my parents
and still be financially stable?
And what skillset am I gonna leverage
in order to make sure that I'm still employable
when I'm not doing what my degree says
I should be doing?
On the second prong of that audit, the whole,
like, how do you begin to unpack and answer that?
That's where journaling really came into the picture.
And journaling vision boards and honestly, social media,
like, the storytelling and the scrapbook nature
that I approached social media with,
even during like Tumblr days, and gosh,
I don't even know what other platforms.
MySpace.
I did have a MySpace, I had a friend star (laughs).
I think it's important to point that out
because people have, through the rear view mirror,
people have a very condensed idea
of what the timeline looked like.
Like, you were well along this journey when I met you,
and was that like, I don't know, eight years ago
or something like that, nine years ago?
Yeah, eight or nine.
You had already been at it for quite a number of years.
This is something I'm always reminding people
about my own story.
Like, these things don't happen.
I mean, overnight is an absurd notion, it's decades for me
of constantly growing and trying to figure this out,
and doing it imperfectly, and incorrectly, and inelegantly.
And your initial move out
of the law was really as a journalist.
Yes, I thought I was gonna...
'Cause I think it's human nature to go
to the frameworks that are already existing.
And I thought, "Okay, if I know how to write
and I love sports, then obviously I'm just gonna go write
for a sports magazine."
Yeah, that's a strength as a lawyer,
you know how to write, you have this love for running.
It's not immediately apparent how that's gonna translate
into anything that's gonna pay your rent.
(laughs) Right.
You're not gonna win the New York Marathon,
and even if you did,
that would probably barely pay your rent.
Exactly, there's no longevity in that.
Like, how does this whole thing scale?
That was the question of asking myself,
"How does this scale?"
I put on my vision board disruptive technology,
and then I read about Peloton,
a blurb about Peloton and fast company.
And it was not even like a 200-word blurb,
it was like, on the side bar.
And I thought, "Oh," and that for me
was how vision boards help is that they enable you
to name it and claim it.
And I think I would've glossed right by that blurb
if I hadn't planted the seed that I wanted some type
of disruptive technology to partner run.
Yeah, that's interesting.
And so did you just cold call?
Like, how did that cold email relationship develop?
I sent an email to like, info at.
Wow.
And I had been teaching cycling at a local spin studio
in New York City, and then I read about Peloton,
and I just looked it up on the internet, and I, info at,
there were like, 20 employees at the time, and I was like,
"Let's do this, I am your chic."
And they said yes (laughs).
Wow!
So when people come to you and say,
"I'm looking at trying to make some version
of your life pivot journaling,"
what else do you tell them?
I think the three most relevant questions
that I asked myself during that transition period,
and still continue to ask myself, "Why not me?"
You know, like, we tend to other people's greatness
instead of understanding that in the kaleidoscope
of how we see things,
what if that greatness is being refracted as potential?
Like, now I see somebody else's greatness as a potential
of my own, not in a apples to apples comparison of course,
necessarily, but as potential.
So folks, ask yourself, "Why not me?"
And the second question that I've asked myself,
which we talked about a little was like, "What is my why?"
I do believe like, identifying that
with as much specificity as possible,
and acknowledging that sometimes that's gonna change
in different seasons is freeing.
I give myself permission to change my mind
as a stubborn individual, as a stubborn Virgo,
former lawyer that is incredibly freeing,
to give myself permission to change my mind.
And the third most exciting question
is what decision would I make if I were twice
as confident and twice as strong?
And that--
That's a good one.
That one, I asked myself a lot, especially postpartum.
It was like, "What decision would I make
if I were twice as confident?"
And that actually is a nice tool
against imposter syndrome too.
It's kind of an alter ego exercise.
Yes, and I love like, the lore around superheroes
and stuff like that.
And actually, this is related to Web 3
is like, that level of enchantment I think
is really exciting of like, I do talk a lot about royalty,
and polishing crowns, and I think there's a level
of self-determination and imbuing respect
when you call someone a king or a queen,
or non-binary royalty.
And there is like, another version of myself that I try
to honor, whether you call it an avatar, alter ego.
When you conjure that,
what does that look like in your mind?
Like, she is regal.
She has earned jewels in her crown through grit.
And I, yeah, I mean, it's like a version of myself
that is otherworldly, but like, she's on a throne, honey,
and don't play with her.
And I really think about that version of myself,
or that imagined version of myself often.
And I'm creating a kingdom with my husband.
And Athena is gonna be a part of that,
but I also wanted her to like earn--
Appropriately named in the goddess vernacular.
Yeah, but I also want her to be able to earn
and define her own way, you know?
So that's an interesting thing that I'll navigate
as she gets older, but yeah.
Another big piece of that you talk about
is being unapologetic,
but that is befitting of a queen, right?
Or of royalty.
Yeah,
Well, I've learned to use my voice
even when it's shaky, like, use it
and you'll find your people.
And that paired with having enough confidence
to know when you should have done better.
You know, I think using your voice, even when it shakes,
and having an ability to admit when you're wrong
and change your mind are lethal combinations.
And then not fearing other people's success,
which we talked about earlier.
Yeah, I find it totally intoxicating
and palpable when somebody is like, "Step into your power,"
like, "Polish your crown baby."
Like, that just means that I am surrounded by royalty.
That excites me.
Let's talk about the T1,
that's another big piece in your story
being type one diabetic.
You're healthy, everything's good, right?
Thank goodness.
Your health and stuff,
with regards to that.
I've been playing around with a CGM.
Oh, cool.
All through levels, and it's been really interesting.
And I've thought of you often as I'm like,
checking my blank glucose, 'cause we go to dinner
and you're kind of, I'm like,
"Why is she so distracted?"
And it's like, no, as you're doing right now.
I am doing right now, yeah (laughs).
I like how it's on the Apple Watch.
But it's been really interesting to see that relationship
between the foods that I'm eating
and how it's impacting that graph of blood glucose going up,
going down, when is it plateau?
What really spikes it?
What doesn't?
How does sleep, rest, recovery, training,
all these other lifestyle habits impact that?
That's probably been the most revelatory, it's like,
obviously, if you eat something that's high
in simple carbohydrates, it's gonna do this.
I've also noticed that foods that are higher
in fat will do the same thing.
I think the danger with this is that people
who aren't steeped in the science can make very binary,
reductive conclusions from that data.
I think the truth is probably much more complex,
but as somebody who's been dealing with this condition
that you have for a very long time and is very schooled
on how these CGMs work and all of that,
like, what have you learned about yourself,
and how do you think this kind of technology
could be helpful for somebody who doesn't suffer
from type one?
Oh, that's interesting.
I mean, yeah, body awareness is key.
I'm very grateful that I was already plant based,
and I was already an athlete when I was diagnosed.
So there's a level of self awareness
that I already had going into my type one diagnosis.
And then I just told myself,
"I'm gonna continue to run these finish lines.
I'ma cross these finish lines.
I'm gonna continue to lift weights.
I'm gonna continue to teach a Peloton."
Like, actually, I was just on the eve
of teaching a Peloton when I was diagnosed.
And this, the time is different now,
because now there's an acceptance of this.
But when you were starting,
I know that people thought that that was inadvisable
or perhaps even very dangerous.
Oh, I was told, "You're not gonna run ultras anymore."
Like, "How are you gonna be able to teach
in front of a camera and not having to go..."
The doctors couldn't even contemplate me teaching
in front of millions of people
and not having to pause the class to leave and do whatever,
which knock on wood has never happened.
I mean, the technology helps a lot,
so I have a Dexcom G6,
and I loop that basically, you create like a bridge
through an app and through this Bluetooth device
that links the blood sugar device
with an insulin distribution system.
Right, and you can just refresh it every couple minutes
or whatever, and you can kind of see pretty much
in real time what's happening.
You're seeing the numbers in real time,
but I'm also administering like, the device, the algorithm,
is administering the insulin based on the setting.
So it's reading it and deciding how much, if,
and when the insulin gets right from the device on your arm.
Right, yeah, and that helps hugely.
And I approached my care, I was like,
I can either resist and get frustrated,
or I can get curious.
And I just got really freaking curious about everything,
from like, if I work out at this time and I eat this
portion of my smoothie before this type of workout,
and I, now I kind of (laughs)
I know how to move the needle,
you know, all those little nuances matter so much.
Yeah, and they're gonna be very specific
to you as an individual, and also very differentiated
because you have type one, what's interesting now
is that there's adoption of a version of this device.
Obviously, it's not injecting you with insulin,
but with mainstream people.
And I think there's a portion
of society that is frowning upon this.
Like, this thing is intended
for people with diabetes, right?
Like, this shouldn't be being used by mainstream people.
And then the counterpoint being like,
"Hey, all information is good.
This is gonna help us make better decisions.
We're gonna get these massive data sets.
We're gonna better understand how foods
and lifestyle habits are impacting blood glucose,"
which is really important in helping people prevent
themselves from getting type two
or other lifestyle illnesses.
For sure, it's a massive biomarker.
I mean, I don't, unless the, the former criticism
is presuming that having that type
of technology widely available somehow inhibits
or prevents type ones from having access to it,
I don't see the issue.
It's like--
Right, unless there's a supply chain problem.
You're right, unless--
I think part of the criticism also
is what I referenced earlier that people
who don't really understand will make
really reductive conclusions about sort of A plus B equal C
when that's probably not really the case.
And then sort of saying, "Well, this is the case,
so here's how I need to eat,"
or, "Here's this is happening because of this,"
where it's probably a much more complex
physiological mechanism than what is revealed
by a simple graph.
Sure, but you could say that about anything.
You could say that about the sleep trackers, you could say,
I mean, literally any of this biometric data,
you could be making reductive decisions that aren't nuanced.
But I think that we can use this data.
I would love for people to be more intentional
about their food choices
and see how their bodies are reacting.
Most people don't understand that you shouldn't feel like
you were hit by a truck and you're so lethargic
and fatigued every day at three o'clock
after you've had lunch, you know?
And it's like, if that data point helps people understand
that, then great.
Yeah, and being able to see like, "Oh man,
like, I feel that way, 'cause yeah, here's this."
And like, "Oh, it's taking me a long time
to get back up here.
The other day I ate this and I bounce back more quickly."
Like, all of these are really helpful, I think.
It's potentially transformative technology
when it's sort of adopted at scale,
which I think will happen at some point.
Definitely, especially if people can, and I mean,
listen, diabetes, especially type two is an epidemic.
If we can prevent folks from reaching that point of crisis--
The percent of Americans that are gonna be diabetic
or prediabetic by like, 2050, it's insane.
Yeah, it's pretty terrifying.
So we need to do something,
and we can start with that education tool.
I agree.
Yeah, what else do we want to talk about?
Let's talk about a day in the life.
What's the day in the life look for like for you now,
it's a little bit different than last time we talked.
It's a little different.
Complicated.
Yeah, I wake up--
I got four, so you know, but they're older now, it's easy.
Four, it's incredible.
Day in the life, I used to wake up and meditate,
now I wake up and feed Athena.
Well, you gotta wake up in the night too, right?
I used to, now she sleeps through the night,
and I don't need to pump during the night,
but I'll wake up around--
She sleeps through the night.
She sleeps through the night, put her down at 6:30,
she wakes up at 6:30.
Wow.
It's pretty remarkable.
I'm very grateful.
That's like you won the lottery with that.
I know I did, I know I won the lottery there.
So wake up, feed Athena.
Mornings in our house are really sacred,
so it's like, we play music,
it's family time for 90 minutes.
And then my husband will take the baby, feed her.
She has a plant-based smoothie in the morning for breakfast.
Actually, the whole family has the same plant-based meal.
Yeah, and you're still on the plant-based diet?
Yeah.
It's working for you.
Love it.
Good.
Like, most of my family members are now plant-based,
so it's cool to see (laughs).
That's good.
It's spread a little bit.
Did people tell you that you should modify that
when you were pregnant, and how was the experience
of being plant-based through pregnancy?
'Cause I think that's something a lot of plant-curious
or even plant-based people think about women
when they get pregnant, like,
"Hey, maybe I need more iron, or I need more of this."
And obviously, nobody wants to do anything
that would be harmful to their baby.
Yeah, of course.
Well, I think because I was already a plant-based athlete,
it answered a lot of those questions.
So I already had blood work to understand like,
what are my vitamin D, B, 12, and iron levels?
And I do supplement all three.
And the protein question that
is like the classic plant-based protein question,
I already had a understanding of how much protein
I was getting to sustain very, very, two, three hours
of training a day, most days.
And so going into pregnancy,
I kind of knew what my baseline was,
and that it was actually well above
and beyond what they recommend
for a pregnant human,
let alone a pregnant plant-based athlete.
So yeah, I felt really confident.
And to add to it, the fact that it was a type one pregnancy,
and you wanna keep your blood sugar
within non-diabetic ranges,
I wasn't gonna upset the apple cart too much.
It was like, if I know if I can eat this, this, and that,
and this is what works before and after training,
and different parts of my day,
you know, the nuances that we just discussed
as someone living with type one.
I was just gonna keep rocking with that,
and it worked well for me.
Good, all right, so plant-based smoothie in the morning.
Oh, plant-based smoothie in the morning,
and then I'll do my first training session.
So usually in the morning, I have a lifting session,
barbell work, everything from--
Just at home?
I'll go to a private training facility to do that.
And then three or four days a week, I'll do a run.
So 45 minutes to an hour of running,
and then I'll normally teach midmorning
to afternoon, a Peloton.
So I'll teach a handful of classes four days a week.
Do you bank those in a row, or how does that work?
Usually, so a few days a week I teach live classes
where it'll be like, a 30-minute and a 20-minute.
Or a 45.
Usually, it's an under an hour of content live,
and then sometimes I'm teaching up to two hours
of content banked.
So it might be like a bunch of,
might be as many as five classes,
but like about two hours of content total.
Yeah.
And then...
Then it's meetings.
It's either meetings with my agent, with Drew,
on some of the projects that we're working on.
Afternoons are usually like, meetings
or any kind of written, or like mind solitary,
like, computer work that I have to do.
Do you have an assistant like--
I do.
You do?
My gosh, yeah, I would not function
without my assistant, Karen, (laughs) for sure.
And then early to bed?
Early to bed, yeah.
Then it's like, make dinner, wrap up the day,
hop on, after we put Athena to bed,
it's usually back on the computer for a little bit,
for like, more emails and stuff.
And then I go to bed pretty early, yeah.
By eight, nine o'clock, it's a wrap.
Yeah, that's pretty manageable.
Yes, it really is, I've created a life that aligns
with how I wanna present in the world,
and I'm grateful as hell that I get to honestly see
my daughter as much as I do.
Like, I remember my mom, who's a practicing physician still.
So there were some days she would leave at seven
in the morning and get back at seven at night.
And at least now, even though I'm busy
and my daughter is with our nanny who we love
and I'm very grateful for,
I can dip in and out and at least see her for 15,
20 minutes throughout the day,
and still feel like I'm honoring my work life
and being productive.
And how does it work with social media?
I mean, you have almost like a million people
that are following you on Instagram.
Do you feel pressure to be posting and sharing insights,
or how do you kind of calibrate how you interact
with that to maintain some level
of privacy and groundedness?
Because that's a lot of people.
I suspect probably you feel some pressure
to be servicing that.
Yeah, I mean, the storytelling
around that is very organic.
So we kind of have,
I've developed the social media strategy
and I kind of know what's gonna live
in different verticals of that.
So like, there's like the Peloton stuff, there's motivation,
there's the mom stuff, you know?
And then there's stuff like this week
where I'm just posting organically when I feel like it.
I had to decide a long time ago
to take the pressure off of that.
So it's...
You don't have rules?
Like, every day I do this or absolutely not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely not, no.
That's the only way that I can stay sane
with the whole thing.
Like, my rule is like, I only post when I feel like it,
and if I don't feel like it, like,
you just can't be held hostage by it.
Like, it's just not healthy.
I agree, do you have notifications on your phone
from all these things?
No, I don't have any notifications for anything.
Me neither (laughs).
So then like in the household though,
like, one of my kids is texting me,
and I don't get, its like, if I'm not checking my phone,
they're like, "I texted you (indistinct)."
Sorry--
Well, this perception of imediacy
of in response to anything,
I mean, I remember, when you practice law,
people probably still sent written letters.
Yeah, of course.
(laughs) So there was like, a list--
Which was in art form,
especially like the demand letter.
Like, "How snarky can I be in this letter?"
You pour over it for hours.
Yeah, I mean, and I'm prey to, just like anybody else,
you know, the distractions and this perception
that time is, that we need to be as immediate
with our response as it was in the sender's perception,
and I really try to release myself from those expectations.
Yeah, that's healthy, and go to Coachella.
Exactly (laughs).
What else do I want to talk to you about?
I mean, I think it's really cool what you've built,
and what you stand for, and what you've done,
and to like own your strength,
I think is really not just powerful, but infectious.
And I think part of your appeal,
if I had to guess, is that everyone wants
to feel a little bit more empowered.
Like, they see you talking about crowns
and owning your space and all of that.
And I think to some degree, we all self-coagulate
and we all have insecurities.
And to see you as this (indistinct) going,
"No, do this instead,"
like, I need a little bit more of that in my life.
Like, I want that.
So for people that are feeling that urge,
or that pull, or that yearning
for a little bit more self-efficacy
and agency in their life,
maybe it would be helpful to just kind
of share spontaneously a little bit of that wisdom.
Sure, I mean, I do think a lot
of your listeners have some type of movement practice.
I think that movement has changed my life.
I didn't know I wasn't an athlete as a kid.
I was completely terrified of gym class.
I told myself I was like, I used to get made fun of
for the way I ran when I was in recess or whatever.
So I told myself this story at a really young age
that I was the straight A student arts and crafts kid.
And that's who I was.
And I am introverted by nature,
so those, being good at school and doing arts
and crafts really suited my nature.
And movement has unlocked a wellspring of confidence.
And I do believe that confidence is a side effect of hustle.
I think that you have to really drill down on what form
of hustle feels rewarding, and is getting you closer
to the finish line of your own definition.
And a regular movement practice is crucial,
no matter what that looks like.
For me, another tool in the toolkit is storytelling.
Like, I think when we're brave enough to tell our stories,
it frees up our ability to imagine our,
the answers to those questions, right?
It's like, what is my why?
What decision would I make if I were twice as confident?
Those existential, who am I moments.
Why not me?
Those things are always kind of percolating in my head,
but it's really crucial to me that folks
give themselves permission to win.
Where sometimes success feels as uncomfortable
as the work that it took to get there,
and I want folks to give themselves permission
to step into the light.
Like, I wanna stand closer to the folks
who illuminate you, and even pay attention
to who and what that is.
Like, most people would have to think long
and hard about the experiences that even bring them
the most joy are the people that they're with
when they experience joy
or what joy even feels like recently.
We should be centering those conversations more.
Yeah, I think that's powerful.
That goes to that second tier that we were talking
about, the who am I thing.
And I think it is true that most people
are so sufficiently disconnected that they aren't aware
of what brings them joy,
or what is driving their decisions,
or the activities that would guard their life
with more purpose and fulfillment and meaning and the like.
And I think a process of starting
to better understand yourself
and what makes you tick is yes in the journaling,
but also, as you mentioned,
having the courage to share your story,
we all have a story, right?
And that courage is born out of a choice to be vulnerable.
Like, the vulnerability is strength because it takes bravery
and courage to share something and allow yourself
to be vulnerable and judged for that.
But my experience and the experience
of many others that I've born witness to,
and yourself as well, is that when you can summon that
and engage with that, like, grapple with that,
there is a level of self-efficacy and self-esteem
that derives from that that allows you
to be more self-integrated and self-actualized
to stand in that power, to adorn that crown.
And like, claim your truth and your path.
Well, speaking your story, speaking your truth
is gonna magnetize your people.
I think about, that's what I've done,
of course, it's on a very public platform,
be it social media or Peloton,
but speaking my truth has magnetized people
who that truth resonates with.
Yeah, that's the lighthouse thing.
That's the light, exactly,
it's the lighthouse thing, is like,
how are your people gonna find you if you're confused,
misaligned, and obfuscating who you are?
And then part of movement
and our movement practices are an ability
to discover who that person even is.
Something that I ask myself
as a touch point pretty frequently are like,
what are my recent moments of flow?
Am I still finding moments of flow
where I'm losing track of time?
Not because I'm scrolling on social media,
but because I'm so immersed with focus and alignment,
feelings of alignment and fulfillment.
Am I centering those experiences throughout my work day?
And I definitely go through periods
where that isn't as much the case.
And it's like my what.
It's more disciplined
to do that now--
So much.
Than it ever has before.
But I would say most people don't ask themselves
that question of, "When am I experiencing moments of flow?"
Yeah, it's so easy and reflexive to just grab the phone.
My eldest stepson, Tyler, just got the light phone,
which has nothing on it except only like, texting.
And he's like, "In the first week, I read two books."
You know, and he's like,
"I'm doing all these things that I'd never done before."
And he has his other iPhone, he just has it in a drawer,
you know, and checks it once in a while or whatever.
But when he is out in the world, he's like, "Yeah,
I was standing in a line the other day and there was nothing
for me to do except be with myself."
And it was like a revelation.
And I'm as guilty as anyone of that to exercise,
as a disciplined person, I find myself powerless at times
to exercise the discipline required to carve out
the quiet time to do the deep work,
to accomplish the more important things just.
Just to even be bored.
I actually, on that note, I made a rule this year
to not grab my phone when I'm in elevators.
And even when I'm like,
just on the cusp of sending an email,
when I get into the elevator, to force myself to like,
even just be aware and have a human interaction.
But then you're like, it's creepy.
Now, I force myself in that.
And I am very allergic to like, (laughs)
I don't like small talk,
but I find that it's like, just let your mind...
When's the last time that I let my mind wander?
I'm always just, again, grabbing from my phone,
refreshing the email, like, checking Instagram.
And the wandering mind is the bread and butter
of any creative inspiration.
And if you deprive yourself of that,
it's a form of self-harm.
Journaling also helps, 'cause there are some days
where I don't feel like I have anything to journal,
but I'll just set five minutes, a five-minute time
around my phone and something always pours out.
So what is the structure to the journaling?
Is it like morning pages where it's just sort
of a vomitous thing?
Or do you approach it with a certain intention?
Usually, it's in the evening actually, before I go to bed,
I find that my mornings are a lot focused on Athena.
So it's evening focused.
And sometimes there's an emotionality
to it where it's just like,
I'm frustrated about this or that,
and it's more of like a dear diary moment.
But the days where I don't feel like I have anything
to write, I will literally just set a timer and dream.
You know, whether it's like, I'll ask myself questions,
like, who is a dream partnership?
Or like, what would success look like in Q1?
You know, how are you defining that for yourself?
So sometimes it's like, business ideations,
and sometimes it's more personal.
And then it's that gratitude thing.
I ask myself that pretty frequently, like,
"What do you have right now that you used to dream about
or pray for?"
And I also find that with a gratitude practice,
there's a recency that helps saying three things
that you're grateful for.
Like, I'm always gonna say Athena, Drew, my family.
And then that kind of takes away from the special feeling.
Being very specific and temporal.
Yeah, temporal, like, it'll be like, in the last 12 hours,
what's something that you're grateful for that occurred,
or that you witnessed in that recent time period?
And that helps too.
And what goes into the morning smoothie?
Oh gosh, my husband is actually the smoothie king.
So I use AG1.
He's jacked.
He is jacked (laughs).
He's plant-based too?
Plant based.
He's completely ripped.
He's a strong individual (laughs).
He's very strong young man.
So yeah, we use AG1 plant protein,
we mix up what kind of protein we use all the time.
Magnesium, vitamin D, greens like spinach, kale,
whatever we have in the fridge.
Yeah, there's like, 17 ingredients (laughs).
And how has your marriage evolved
from being just the two of you to being three?
Like, what are the things that you've learned
about being in partnership?
And also now, like this Web 3 thing,
like, you're kind of, commingled a little bit professionally
in a way that you weren't previously.
What are the challenges that you faced,
and what are some of the lessons that you learned
about what's required to stay together?
Wasn't until we had Athena that I understood
that it was like, I have my life, Drew has his life,
and then our marriage is like, another life
that we both pour into.
Whereas it all felt very like, yeah, that's my husband,
of course, I love him, we do our thing.
Now it's the date nights and making sure that we have time
for each other, which all just, it was like, every,
all the time was time with each other before Athena,
and now as life busies, that has now risen to the top
of the list of making sure
that I'm prioritizing my time with him.
And we've done a great job, travel
and adventure is part of who is in the DNA
of our relationship.
We actually got engaged 72 hours after meeting each other,
and then got married at Burning Man three months later.
I know that, I knew that.
So we believe we're like multiple lifetimes in,
and we have a very cosmic connection.
(indistinct) in marriage, but then you got married
into loom, right?
Yeah, so we had a Burning Man ceremony three months
after meeting each other,
and then we had a public ceremony
into loom a few years later.
But making sure that we're planning trips,
whether it's this,
we're going to a friend's wedding in Ireland,
we're going back to Burning Man.
And of course, we have trips planned with Athena as well.
We're making sure that we're adventuring as a family,
but also as a couple and individually,
we've both with each taken trips alone since having Athena.
And we're kind of trying to find the right balance,
intentional balance and alignment with our values
of individual time, and then as a family,
and then as a couple.
Anything unforeseen,
or a challenge that you didn't expect?
We communicate like, I'm very clear
with what I need, whether, I think--
That's important.
I think that helps a lot.
I don't expect him to be a mind reader and likewise.
Yeah, 'cause for a lot of partnerships, it's sort of like,
you have to do a little bit of mind reading or anticipation
and the more clear that you can be.
I think everybody benefits from that,
even if it's an uncomfortable truth.
Yeah, yeah, I'm pretty clear.
I mean, (laughs) I remember, Drew was really,
it was incredibly an incredible partner,
you know, when Athena was first home,
I mean, he's an incredible partner always,
but especially as it involved caring for a small human,
our new roommate.
And I would wake up at two in the morning
or however many times at night to feed,
and we set up like, a breastfeeding station
with like, snacks and whatever.
And one time he ate the almond butter sandwich
that I had waiting for, he had prepared,
but he ate like half of it (laughs).
It's like a very clear boundary,
like, you cannot eat my snacks when I'm breastfeeding
at two in the morning.
So little things like that are actually big things.
It's like, we're trying to set each other up for success,
so no one person needs to feel like a mind reader.
Yeah, well, the complexity of the child really ups
the exigency of that communication,
and the planning and all of that,
because it's so easy to default to a routine,
and before you know it, you're leading separate lives
and you haven't really talked.
I see it all the time, and it really requires a level
of conscious awareness to say,
"Hey, oh, we need to stop.
We gotta get in sync here, because otherwise,
we're like, extrapolate that little tiny diversion
and suddenly, we're in very different places
in not too long."
Yeah, well, I'm trying to be aware of the marriage
as an organism, as well as Drew
as a sentient being, and myself.
So it's actually three entities or humans kind
of that we're curating and we're nurturing.
And I mean, three as in the marriage,
and then the two of us individually.
And then of course, our family is an organism,
but that's the more obvious one.
Yeah, I like the idea of the separate trips thing.
I mean, that's something that Julie and I have done as well.
It's sort of like, you're your own human,
I don't need you to complete me.
We're awesome together, but I don't wanna stand in the way
of you having the experiences
in your life that you wanna have.
Like, you have to have that green light
for that type of thing, and obviously, it has to work
within the construct of the family,
but I found that to be going both ways
in our marriage to be really beneficial.
Yeah, and then you have interesting things to talk about.
Like, I want him to feel fulfilled,
and it's an opportunity to miss each other.
I think that that's a very good thing.
Yeah.
Is New York still your boyfriend?
New York is still my boyfriend.
You're still cheating on your husband with New York?
(laughs) Well, thankfully, Drew also is in love
with New York, so I would say New York's just an element
of our marriage at this point.
(indistinct)
Yeah, exactly, we love New York.
(indistinct) to get attended to,
the other individual in the relationship.
Yeah, yeah, now, New York is home base for sure.
We bought a home in New York.
We're gonna be applying to schools in New York for Athena.
That looks that's a whole thing.
Is New York coming back?
New York's--
New York's back.
Rollercoaster ride, but I was back there last spring,
and I was like, is this off the hook?
Like, I don't know what everyone's talking about.
It's buzzing.
I mean, Midtown, maybe not so much, but--
Yeah, I mean, I thought they shuttered
businesses and stuff, but--
When the weather got nice, everyone was out
and it seemed like there was a lot of energy.
People are out and about.
People are craving interactions, and I don't go out
to night clubs or anything really anymore,
but my friends who do are like,
it is back in a way that unprecedented number.
Of course, it is, because New York City is undefeated.
And resilient as hell.
Like, we are always gonna find a way
to maintain the swagger.
Yeah, I miss it.
You have plane right away.
I know, I gotta come back this spring at some point.
Well, let's round this out
with maybe a final few thoughts
for the person who is struggling to get off the couch,
who's contemplating that movement practice,
who's looking for a little bit of direction
and maybe purpose in their life,
like, get 'em off the couch.
Oh my God.
Come on, this is what you do.
Listen, you gotta start with one,
if you don't like something, change it.
I think that excuses are lies
that we tell ourselves convincingly.
And how many episodes of the RRP are you gonna listen
to before you get off (laughs)?
I mean, come on, right?
But it really starts with one,
it can be really intimidating to look
at the social media feed and think that everybody ran
a marathon before 6:00 ,
and they all are a five-minute mile, you know what I mean?
There's the other side to that aspirational,
you know, the inspiration business is feeling like,
"Ugh, that just made me feel paralyzed
with what I'm capable of," so start with one.
Literally start with one, like, lace up, do one block,
do one Peloton workout, like, do one.
And then that's why I say that confidence
is a side effect of hustle,
because when you take those little nibbles of hustle,
you discover that you really had the power all along,
and then that becomes a fulfilling prophecy.
And when you realize that you are a self-generated factory
of power yeah, your life changes.
When you develop an appetite for your own power,
mediocrity doesn't taste so good anymore.
Polish your crown.
(laughs) That's right.
Always a pleasure, Robin, thank you so much.
You are an inspiration, I love you dearly.
I think it's so cool what you're doing in the world.
I love you too.
Thanks for having me, this is nice to see you, friends.
Yeah, I know we did it in our way.
We did it.
We'll do it again in New York at some point, I'm sure.
You're always welcome here, it's been too long.
So thank you for sharing your wisdom.
Everybody should check out Robin's masterclass.
Where do they find that?
Is it masterclass.com?
Yeah, Masterclass app.
masterclass.com?
Hm-mm.
The app, right, of course.
And "Strong Mama," the new book?
"Strong Mama" is my children's book,
and of course you can find me at Peloton
and robinaddison.com.
There you go, all the stuff, all right.
All right, love you, Robin, thank you.
I love you too, thanks for having me.
(indistinct) plans.
(upbeat music)